all right y'all Before We Say Goodbye
let's take a quick dive into the world
of social media this is what I'm
[Music]
liking so earlier the cast of shuck
impressed us all with their vocal
talents it was so amazing but there is
another little Broadway star impressing
people online uh this time through
kosing I know this is 12-year-old
Michael his crafting skills are the star
of his Instagram he crochets everything
from shirts to blankets to hats and you
will never guess who taught him Tony
Award winning Broadway actress Sutton
Foster actually taught him to crochet
which I think is amazing let's get this
little crochet Star in here watching on
NBC New York say hi to Michael
everybody
hi what's up Michael Hi how are you oh
my God I'm so excited did you make your
shirt yes I did I actually made it in a
movie this summer before the straight oh
you look so great oh my gosh so Sutton
Foster taught you right like how did
that happened so I was on Music Man on
Broadway last year and backstage we were
all a little rambunctious so Sun Foster
the legendary actress taught us how to
crochet and I always remember this one
time where I crocheted this blanket it
was wonky it was horrible I don't even
know what I did but I took it to Sutton
and she was so proud and she said it was
great but then when I got home I really
looked at it and I was like this woman
deserves a Tony an Oscar she was the
best actress I knew because that blanket
was
horrible no I will say one time I I gave
some of the coaches at the voice when I
worked on there uh quilts that I made
they were sad if you looked if you look
closely but if you were far away it was
like oh um so we have one of Michael's
pieces this is a cardigan that he
crocheted and I wanted to this is so
cool how long did this take so it took
around four to five days but the
challenge was like the design so I chose
that hot pink because it fits your
person personality your sassy fun and
iose wait what do you mean my
personality is this for me yes
oh yeah and if you look on the back and
if you look on the back it says MCX
Casey cuz that's the ultimate collab oh
I love it this is so sweet I'm going to
wear this around here oh it's right
there I love you so much Michael thank
you so much I love you too all right
everybody so Michael I'm liking your
purst right now but that's not all okay
our season long oh this is cozy and warm
all right son okay our season long
partner pilot pin makers of friction the
go-to rasal pin of the Kelly Clarkson
show want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you so they're
going to give you $1,000 just for being
rad thank you so much and your shirt is
so cool the sweater is so cool man thank
you so much Michael thank you to all our
guests this hour Mario Lopez Shane MC
gray hon johnman the past Shu your
incredible Dave hilarious Annie Stark
and Lauren Darion y'all have a great day
it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
turn thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home